josh is with us in Missouri hey Josh
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave
how's it going better than I deserve
how can Christie and I help so I guess
I'll try to make a long story short here
I have been on the plane for a couple of
years and have really enjoyed it and
I've kind of spread the word to friends
and sat down with them and sort of help
them run their numbers and see what
their finances can look like on your
plan and I've been kind of looking for a
way to legitimize that but being still
in baby said to myself the financial
coach master training is not really in
the cards at the moment but a friend
approached me basically asking if I had
ever considered a career in financial
planning or at least a side hustle and
he invited me to a meeting and I googled
the name of the company and their
beliefs aligned very closely with yours
and so I went and met with them and got
signed up and then afterwards I kind of
did some more research and discovered
that this is an MLM which made me a
little bit skeptical and I've heard what
you have to say about MLM but I don't
feel like I really need the personality
type that succeeds in that so basically
I'm looking for like what are sort of
some things that I should be looking out
for and like how will I know whether
this is for me or not well I think one
of the things that would bother me
immediately as I signed up for something
and they weren't clear that they were an
MLM they hid that mm-hmm and that that's
a red flag may not necessarily be a
company-wide issue it might just be that
particular hierarchy that that's how
they've decided to not talk it through
but it's not going to be very successful
for them because the secret to an MLM is
to recruit the right people that know
how to recruit and train people not
necessarily to move the particular
product that's where the success comes
and MLM ziz the building of a hierarchy
it's not the moving a product and it's
you know it's the way the business is
done so
you know that if you're asking should
you stay in it I think that's one red
flag that the particular hierarchy at
least that you've gotten in
intentionally or otherwise you were you
were not presented a full picture before
they took your money
you know that's disturbing then the
second thing is you know you just got to
get into it and say are these products
that I actually want to represent and
that's fairly easy to do you can shop
the products and say you know is this
insurance can I get this insurance
cheaper through Zander can I get the and
if so then you got a problem right and
are the investment is the investment
advice solid I mean is there some
training involved is there some stuff
I'm gonna get to get to be a part of
there that makes sense and those are the
red flags you're looking for is just can
I can I get through this with my
integrity intact when I talk to my
friends about the business that I'm in
and that's important to Krista you got
to be able to feel comfortable with the
process yeah and you know you just hit
on something that I think is really
important and I've heard you talk about
this before when it comes to direct
sales multi-level marketing companies
what makes people the most frustrated a
lot of times when they get into those is
they thought it was one thing but it
ends up being another if if someone
comes to you says hey I want to you know
recruit you to recruit people to recruit
people and you love recruiting people
cool go do the thing and recruit people
that's your thing awesome but if I if I
pitch you hey you're gonna sell life
insurance investments whatever the thing
is but your actual comp is attached to
you recruiting people and you don't want
to recruit people then then you're not
in the right spot you're not going to be
you're not going to be doing something
that you is in line with what you're
good at what you want to do what you
thought you were doing and it can be
very difficult to be successful so I
think it's really important to
understand how you earn an income
through this business is it attached to
the work you actually want to be doing
and that's what gives multi-levels a bad
name I know I know and I have a lot of
women in direct sales in the Academy in
the business boutique and many of them
are successful and I'm constantly
reminding them everyone is not in your
target market everyone is not a prospect
you need to find people that want to do
the thing that you're doing and
everybody
else leave them alone because it's
giving you a bad name yeah I mean I you
know I've had people try you know I'm
running a 250 million dollar business
and they're gonna recruit me I know they
yeah you'd be really great at it you
know you're gonna say oh I probably
would be yeah you know but it's just
it's it's just humorous so what do you
think you lose credibility I mean
there's you it destroys what a portion
of my MLM that is legitimate right is
destroyed by that by that attitude in
that process and that's exactly what
you're running into right